quand on pense à dijon on pense surtout
aux touristes ils sont nombreux chaque
année à venir profiter du charme de
l'ancienne capitale des ducs de
bourgogne et quand les habitants ont du
mal à nous dire face caméra ce qu'ils
apprécient à dijon arturo nous explique
ému qu'il a fait le voyage exprès du
mexique pour demander sa petite amie en
mariage
j'aime beaucoup de gens parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de souvenirs quand j'étais
étudiant ici c'est en ville avec
beaucoup de charme
c'est une ville avec beaucoup de vies et
des bons vins dijon une ville qui attire
beaucoup de touristes et quelques cadres
parisiens selon l'étude cadremploi du
mois d'août 8 sur 10 sont prêts à
quitter paris pour vivre en région
parmi eux 6 % seulement viennent
s'installer à dijon loin derrière
bordeaux nantes ou lyon
pourquoi voici un cas concret avec
benoît de région parisienne
il est arrivé en côte d'or lumière son
couloir se chercher en venant à des gens
compétents en sortant de paris c'est
justement avoir un cadre vie idyllique
mais un cadre de vie qui changeait
complètement être posée pouvoir pouvoir
profiter pleinement de ce que je veux et
à l'heure actuelle oui je suis épanoui
finies les galères de transport le
manque de temps ou des loyers trop chers
et même si dijon n'était pas son premier
choix
benoît ne regrette pas du tout sa
décision allez plus être vital ne paraît
après je comprends les gens qui vont
vers lyon nantes ou toulouse sont des
grandes villes qui sont des villes qui
bouge énormément due aux étudiants de
son là bas dijon je le recommanderais
pour les gens vraiment qu'ils veulent tu
vas le s'installer à long terme qu'ils
ont chez soi on coupe on va être une
famille vous êtes très vite le
raccompagne vous pouvez très vite être
déconnecté de tout et la ville et
est très belle et on s'y plaît très vite
pour réaliser ce rêve d'une vie plus
agréable
un cadre sur deux est prêt selon l'étude
a accepté une baisse de salaire